The reason we're replacing the
roundabout with traffic signals is that
over the last 10 years the traffic
volumes  have increased from seventeen
thousand vehicles a day to 24,000 vehicles
a day and so the roundabout just isn't
coping with that level of traffic
especially at peak times.
So traffic signals provide a much better and more
efficient way of managing that traffic
and an added advantage of the traffic
signals is for pedestrians.
Especially with schools in the area
that will provide a much safer route for
children to cross and get to the schools.
So the first stage of the work is working on
the eastern side of the road and that's
where the widening is taking place but
also more importantly it'll enable a new
footpath to be constructed during the
school holidays and by the time the
schools start again there will be a new
footpath constructed, so that will
provide much a safer environment for the
school children while the construction
work then continues after that.
With a project of this size and
complexity, there will be an impact on
commuters and general traffic.
Just be patient if you're using the intersection
but consider using an alternative route if  you can
and certainly avoid peak times if you can.
When the work's finished, the intersection finished
it's going to be a much better intersection and traffic will
be flowing much more freely
so we think the benefits of the end result will be
fantastic and it's just a case of being
patient while we carry out the
construction work.